foreign
yes my name is Dr Ganesh Taylor I don't
normally go with a full title but I
thought for this talk I would actually
state that I do have some modicum of
professional experience and that said
the title says the contraception
delusion and I'm not a professional
expert in contraception what I study is
how it is that embryos actually make the
decision to build ovaries versus testes
okay so I study biological sex something
that many people I think don't know or
don't think about even biologists often
don't think about this is that
biological sex is kind of multi-layered
that's the best way of putting it at the
point of fertilization technically this
schematic is a bit of a loop you right
so it fertilization is the moment where
an egg in a sperm meet for the first
time okay it happens in your mother and
it's all beautiful there's not actually
songs that happen at that point in time
Angels don't actually sing even though
we might think they do
at that point in time your DNA your
genome all comes together for the first
ever time okay and really importantly in
that moment your your DNA your genome
has these sort of volumes one might
think of these things that we call
chromosomes and of them there are two
that are very particular that we call
sex chromosomes so at that very first
point of fertilization the very first
time your genome comes into existence
you have something that we call a
chromosome or sex okay so that's like
you have these chromosomes this is what
you have this is the hand you have been
dealt and 99.9 of people pretty much
across the planet all get either XX or x
y and that is sort of the first layer
that's the foundational layer
okay so you know one cell embryo it
divides it develops it you know there's
a few all of them that happens and you
know you need a bit of materials to
start with before you start building an
entire embryo
but then pretty early on in the
proceedings
about eight weeks six to eight weeks of
human development so six to eight weeks
after fertilization there's a lot going
on the embryos being built there's head
there's limbs there's you know there's a
rough structure going on okay and and
during that time there's a structure
that's built that is actually a bit of a
mouthful to say it's called The
bipotential gonadal Ridge and we
biologists often like to label things
um very literally maybe the Germanic
roots of science it's got something to
do with that I wonder but that thing as
the name indicates has two potentials by
potential that same structure can be
reshaped into either testes or into
ovaries which I think is pretty bloody
amazing
um considering the fact that it's the
literal same cells can we just take a
moment to appreciate that right so the
schematic is here to really highlight
that if you think about it there's this
generic structure made up of these
supporting cells and then and then Bank
to
the DNA on the sex chromosomes and other
bits of DNA in the genome this
incredible molecular mechanism unfolds
that basically ends up telling this
generic structure oh right hey we have a
y chromosome we are going to be making
testes this supporting cell precursor
then matures up to becoming a supporting
cell it reshapes this organ into a load
of tubules they're all designed to
interconnect to to house a particular
group of cells called germ cells and and
germ cells are the cells that will
eventually become if they come to live
in a in a testis they they become so
totally cells they become stem cells
that will make
um that make basically sperm right so
the germ cells are the the cells that
will make the sperm but if those germ
cells come to find themselves in an
ovary rather
they will then become egg cells
basically all right so there's two
really important cell types there's the
germ cells they're the ones that will
become eggs or sperm and there's the
supporting cells and the supporting
cells reshape this thing so as I said
these these supporting cells become one
of two very different things and they
reshape the organ and let's just you
know let's let's now talk also about the
ovary side of things so ovaries
very different to testes right I think
we probably all intuitively have a sense
for that but if you were to cut through
an ovary
um you would see
um quite a dense tissue there's a lot
going on in there and it's all very very
um jam-packed whereas if you actually if
you ever cut it don't I don't recommend
you do this at home but if you ever cut
a testis it's remarkable actually
they're really quite
um they're quite explosive actually they
are really they'll really expand and all
these tubules will come like pouring out
and it's these structures these tubules
are a bit like intestines actually
really inside the testes and that's
where the sperm cells are matured Okay
so this program here this thing that
happens this sort of response this
interpretation of your chromosomal sex
is called sex determination happens
around eight weeks of development in
humans and it's really important because
it basically makes your gonads it it
then says all right we have this DNA
it's been here for eight weeks now what
are we going to do about it step one
build a go now that's appropriate for
the sex chromosomes we have broadly
speaking okay so then you have the
gonads
there's another layer of sex biological
sex
which is all the rest of the apparatus
that's happening around there right it's
not just gonads on their own testes are
connected into the rest of the the sort
of urogenital system females in
particular actually have um obviously
the uterus and the Fallopian tubes and
all these other things that are going on
there's a lot of ducting or pipe work
needs to be plumbed in is what I'm
trying to say okay so then so that's the
third layer there's like everything else
that's going on and then comes
um another layer which we call you know
the genital system basically so that's
like the Aesthetics what kind of sink
are we putting there what's this thing
look like right
um and what's really interesting is
um actually there can be there's well
there is a lot of variety as we all know
from our personal experiences no doubt
um but also medically speaking that is
that is the layer at which there tends
to be a bit more ambiguity it's about
about one in ten thousand one in a
hundred thousand bursts depending on
where you are when born the doctors
might take a look at the gym tools and
be not entirely sure of where it sits
within that so there's a bit more of a
spectrum at that point in time
okay so that's that's all pretty
Hardware style stuff that's going on now
um another important part of this whole
uh system actually is the brain I don't
have a schematic oh no I do I do have a
schematic for this
Bingo sorry I should have put this up
before here it is went past the
Watershed it's all good so um there they
are in their full Glory all of the this
is all the hardware stuff that's going
on and um
what well yes the last part of the the
biological sex system is the part where
the brain has this little gland on the
bottom of it called the pituitary and
the Brain
um signals to the pituitary and the
pituitary also generates sex hormones
okay so the last layer of biological sex
is the hormones effectively well yeah
the hormones that that your system makes
and I haven't said this explicitly so
far so I'm going to
um your your ovaries and your testes
respectively house these important germ
cells that will either become the sperm
or the eggs and this is you know these
are the goods these are the magical
cells that will make the Next Generation
but they also produce hormones and
hormones are these molecules that go
into your bloodstream and are sensed by
every single cell in your body just take
a moment to appreciate that right
hormones are these sort of pervasive
signals that go through your entire body
and the and the ovaries in the testes
make these a lot of hormones but also
your brain releases hormones and there's
this axis that exists between your brain
link to your
um your your pituitary and then your
pituitary releases hormones which then
signal to your gonads and there's this
whole feedback system that exists which
is magical and of course we all know
that when children are born they don't
seem to be particular you know they have
genitals clearly they have the gonads
they have that the hardware but there is
this sort of semi-software situation
that happens that we call puberty right
right that when the system sort of
really activates and then you start to
see more systemic effects through the
release of these hormones right they
they affect all of the cells in the body
but some respond so females will get
breasts the males the Jaws will you know
firm up and the bones will develop
differently and vocal cords and various
systems basically will have very obvious
changes that happen
which is great
so we're here to talk about
contraception because let's just think
about it so this is that's biological
sex well done you're all experts now
that's how this all works that's
fascinating but um if you think about
how humans
um
well we haven't said explicitly and
let's just get this over with is you
know okay so I've talked about this very
biologically and you know of course I
would say as a biologist the whole point
of these systems is so that they can
come together bring together the egg
cell and the sperm cell in this magical
Union Angel sing and then the next
Generation comes out of course we also
know
it's just fun isn't it having sex it's
not all about having babies and humans
have been doing that in time and
Memorial and in fact the the good
feelings and the enjoyment of it is
Evolutions little carrot on the stick
it's like come on you gotta come at me
you like you like this don't you let's
let's have some babies but actually it's
a bit of it's not always the best to be
constantly pregnant or having children
it's not always possible it's um
basically I mean maybe this is a bit of
a judgmental here but it became
societally a little bit inconvenient so
humans have always known this
um that you know the bit of fun happened
it took them a while to figure out but
they did eventually figure out you know
when when the hanky-panky happens a
little bit later
seems babies appear so maybe we should
be a bit careful about that so that thus
came the concept of contraception so in
its basic
um definition contraception is a way of
uncoupling reproduction from the sexual
act essentially okay
so in time time in Memorial humans have
been trying to do this thing and um you
know we have these two different systems
and what's a really good way of doing it
well if you think about how humans might
have looked at other humans bodies and
tried to figure out all right what are
we going to do about this
um
stop that whatever that that stuff is
that comes out of there that's clearly
got something to do with it so put a
sock literally or in the case of the
Egyptians are washed out um intestine
also with a knot at the end that'll do
you know socks sacks blockage blocking
mechanisms have been used by humans as
contraception barrier methods we call
them technically speaking and for a very
long time
so that's that was the original
contraceptive but obviously not we can
all tell an intestine with a knot at the
end of it a not particularly effective
be a bit hard to come by it might ruin
the mood a little bit don't mind me I'm
off to skin a cat and you know all this
was not the best so but that exists
um
many years later of course people do uh
Anatomy
um experiments and we learn a lot more
about this internal system and various
things happening so um this leads me to
saying again importantly in
contraceptives there's now two two major
divisions there's the reversible kind
the kind where you can then remove said
barrier for example all the irreversible
generally irreversible kind
which is called uh yeah the irreversible
coin which in the case of the males
involves things like tube ligations
cutting tying you know these kind of
things that now we know a lot more about
these systems let's just you know
prevent these sperm from being able to
exit from from the testes out again so
that's fascinating
but if you look at the mail system
that's kind of about it really if you
look at it it's like all right sperm get
made they get shipped out they come out
at the end where can we stop this maybe
stop the tubing or maybe put a stopper
on it that's one way of doing it but the
female system
turns out
um once we knew a lot more about it of
course and became a site of many bright
ideas how many different ways can we
stop this from happening how many how
many different ways can we stop females
from getting pregnant right that's the
question so of course again in the
irreversible category or broadly
irreversible category the cheat the
Fallopian tubes are the equivalent to to
the vas deference tubes there so cutting
locking tying ligating
um there's new technologies now
involving bungs that you can stick in
there like surgical ones obviously not
not rubber or anything like that but you
know good old-fashioned blockage methods
are good
um
you know caps diaphragms Rings things
things to block this thing
those things existed they're called the
barrier methods generally speaking they
they sort of fall into the sort of
physically stop this from happening or
like physically disjoining
um parts of the system but you remember
I said that there's this organ that sits
at the bottom of the brain called the
pituitary and it releases hormones so
what actually happened in in some 50
well more than 50 now 70 years ago
people have been doing loads of
experiments and you know studies on
humans and looking for these hormones
and what do they do and what's going on
and this um this shows a sort of summary
of a whole load of information that
people had found out which was namely
well it turns out I hope you can all see
this so it turns out obviously
menstruation and the fact that females
menstruate has been known about for a
long time people have studied this you
know there seems to be some sort of
rhythmicity to it there's a cycle these
things happen you know basically the
lining sort of thickens up it's there
it's ready it seems to correlate with an
approximate timer which you could get
pregnant if no pregnancy occurs of
course the lining sheds and out it comes
then people started learning also about
you know in parallel separate scientists
presumably started learning about all
these hormones that are happening and
then if we find out that there's these
hormones called estrogens
progesterons there's also many other
hormones famously also testosterone of
course we know about in males but
everybody has a bit of all of them
actually it's just to do with the
relative levels of them and then when
you sort of start to Overlay these bits
of information
so estrogen progesterone for example
then you start to see things like oh
there's patterns there's like a
relationship there between what we see
is happening in the uterus and with the
lining and when it's shedding and the
relative levels of the hormones
um just for completeness sake I'll also
highlight the upper one which is um
there's a hormone called follicle
stimulating hormone and another one
called luteinizing hormone and there's
um ovulation basically happens when you
have this sort of buildup of estrogen
followed by this huge peak of what's
called luteinizing hormone that helps
trigger the sort of release of of eggs
okay
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas